Jade has been a status symbol in China
for centuries the country's nouveau
riche spent almost 3 billion dollars a
year on jadeite the purest form of Jade
Jade can fulfill your wishes it brings
luck and protects against accidents and
diseases trucks transport the Jade from
Kachin State in northern Myanmar to
China particularly good pieces are often
brought into China illegally the
smugglers pay the Myanmar army and the
police around 100 thousand dollars for
each truck full of jade we don't profit
from our natural resources the Kachin
Independence Army is fighting for its
autonomy and has been battling Myanmar's
military for control of its natural
resources billions of dollars have been
invested in oil and natural gas
production facilities teak is cut and
jade is mined near the Chinese border
more than a hundred mining companies are
active in pecan Township
those with connections to the hanta
receive the largest prospecting rights
if the mining companies keep it up soon
there won't be any Jade left our lands
are destroyed farmers have had to sell
their land to the mining companies now
they're trying to earn money peddling
Jade people from all over the country
come to Pok hunt to work or search for
Jade in the debris from the mines they
risk their lives in the hope of striking
it rich but hundreds have lost their
lives in landslides da Lu Tung son was
one of the victims he gave me his wages
he wanted to get married that's why he
worked so hard
according to the NGO Global Witness some
30 billion dollars worth of jade was
mined in Myanmar in 2014
a local businessman says some of the
best minds belong to the generals and
they're running them jointly with the
Chinese these mining companies operate
without a license
they bribe the inspectors from the
mining ministry the new democratic
government wants to implement the
initiative for transparency in the raw
materials industry some high-ranking
officials have lost their jobs for
illegally importing excavators from
China such measures are making it more
difficult for politicians and military
officers to line their pockets